avocat d'affaires le jour et bonnes
affaires la nuit voici guillaume faber
interview vérité alors guillaume faveur
bonsoir enfin c'est bien sûr patrons
wallons n'ont n'a pas vraiment sauté
demandé de porter un masque
ce soir c'est parce que d'abord tu
publié un bouquin chez régine de forges
qui s'appelle autoportrait direction on
va en parler et puis c'est ensuite parce
que tu as peur que tu es que tes clients
sachent que tu écris ce genre de bouquin
et aussi le fait que dans ce livre je
parle de femmes
le gendarme était amoureux je voudrais
pas qu'on puisse les reconnaître non
plus enfin les canidés brigitte y en a
pas mal quand même
oui mais en face de la salle et certains
états qui pourraient permettre à leurs
proches de les identifier donc ce serait
à mon avis discours quad parce que tu
dis pour commencer le bouquin c'est que
ce qui est important dans cette
dans cette autobiographie en fait c'est
que avant tout c'est le tokyo graphique
tavergeux prix mais elle est pas l est
pas extraordinaire en plus elle mesure
17 cm est une longueur tudyk est somme
toute assez banal oui de vote que ce
serait cesser dans la bonne moyenne mais
vrai elle fait 3 cm de diamètre c'est
pas terrible je sais pas là thierry fait
mieux mais chez toi tu dis qu'on ne fait
rarement des compliments quand il ya une
fois une fille qui tu as dit que tu
avais une belle que m'enfin c'est pas
non plus c'est pas ça après avoir dit ça
parce que tu les payes à bouffer tu
crois aux non pas du tout non ce n'était
pas ce qu'on a le passé un bon enfant
mais c'était peut-être la reconnaissance
du ventre arrondi fatidique elle est
fonctionnelle et qu'elle s'adapte à tous
types de vagins d'anus de bouche qui est
pas mal seulement les assez passe
partout
c'était alors par contre est beaucoup
moins gentil pour le sexe féminin tu
parles de boursouflures tu parles de
deux formes vague tu dis que c'est que
cet effet par un chirurgien malade et
vieillissant
ça vient d'où cette espèce de désamour
pour le pr le sexe féminin on va je
pense que ça vient de ma culture moi
j'ai été élevé dans le culte de la
statuaire grecque par exemple toutes les
formes sont lisses praxitèle jolie lra
et il est évident que le sexe féminin à
côté attirance homosexuelle
quand esthétiques variées d'expansion
ouais ce serait d'ailleurs sur les
statuts en veut pas par hasard à mon
goût il ya un truc qui te fait pas trop
marrer non plus et le baiser je dirais
tard quand ton jeu
âge maintenant tu dis la bouche des
femmes c'est pour ma verges
le plaisir en fait c'est un substitut à
l'amour ou alors c'est quand on peut pas
faire autrement tu dis qu'on fait des
langues des langues four et les langues
profonde entier dans un ascenseur et
qu'on peut pas baiser quoi oui c'est
d'ailleurs je crois que je suis assez
mauvais au niveau baiser donc d'abord
d'un bon [__] mettez pas la star du
grand besoin j'en sais rien mais si ce
que tu parles de ton dépucelage étudie
que ce jour là avec cette chère lily
tunisie quand même leslie oui tu dit que
c'était quand même six fois de suite
on n'est pas un peu prétentieux ça
suffit au dessus non me sentais pas que
j'avais 50 bouteilles dans quoi la
pression ouais
le pôle performant je prends
vieillissante un peu plus modeste
oui maintenant honnêtement oui je viens
du starter quant à un coût pour retarder
l'éjaculation qui est pas mal
il dirige encore poids des crèmes des
machins des trucs toi c'est pas mal tu
pense à tes factures
tu prends cet effectif qui s'accumulent
sur ton bureau ça marche ouais ça va
ouais alors après il ya tout un tout un
chapitre sur les sur les positions en
missionnaire par exemple en le
missionnaire le début quoi ont ils pas
d'en passer par là mais enfin c'est vrai
que le plan fonctionnel c'est pas du
tout agréable en fin de mois c'est assez
lourd ensuite
donc on vient jouer soutien sur les
coudes et commence à fatiguer mais quand
j'écris un tableau ajoute surtout way
sur les draps rugueux vrai qu'en plus
vous en fais mal non plus le corps d'une
femme
à mon avis une jolie
dans le programme était devenu à
l'amoureux du dos un adepte de la
levrette maintenant je suis pas le seul
trophée pouvoir beaucoup part entre
nouveau dit peut-être pas toujours mais
c'est vrai d'ailleurs que la position
naturelle au physiologiste je prends
comme une basse terre mais oui mais on
n'est pas pour que l'amour en fait mais
de qualité
une belle expression c'est la paresseuse
chose à joli mois oui c'est pas moi qui
l'inventé je les trouvais dans un
bouquin libertin je trouve que le
correspond tout à fait inconnu sur le
côté oui c'est ça on peut même pas
rester sans dormir
ces paresseux une passion qui ont hormis
en disant bons parents qui manquent
l'amazone n'est pas fanatique enfuis
quand suis vraiment fatigué oui il ya
une chose que je dois prendre une femme
propres la masturbation pas reconduit
c'est la panacée universelle explique
nous comment faire une bonne
masturbation imagine que les gens nous
regardent sont dans leur lit
oui je crois que chacun a un double
intérêt pendant dix minutes après
l'émission qui et comment ils s'y
prennent je pense que chacun a sa
manière de se masturber disons qu'ici
rue de l'alizé la plupart des gens
refusent de reconnaître qu'ils se
masturbant très content on en parle un
peu avec eux aussi bien les hommes que
les femmes d'ailleurs ils reconnaissent
qu'ils le font ils en ont un peu honte
alors pour avoir des détails c'est
difficile pour moi je connais une jeune
fille par exemple qui se masturber dans
sa douche avec le pommeau de la douche
en réglant la pression etc
il semblait assez raffiné d'ailleurs
mais elle osait dire à personne donc
chacun a sa technique
non c'est pas comme la fellation cette
salle a fait la ciotat c'est un grand
talent être parce que tu dis que
finalement la douche de la femme c'est
le meilleur réceptacle pour la recherche
de l'homme
non mais je ne suis pas je parle j'ai
tous les hommes prend comme moi font les
frais en force que tous les hommes qui
pour me rendre à l'amour dans tout mort
en championnat une fellation
ah bon les hommes qui les lèvres il en
avait fait voir un certain cardinal donc
on pense que et c'est anwar parce que
avec la fondation sais pas pourquoi le
40 à 140 et c est alors qu on est un peu
usé baroque la whey la sodomie voilée à
la sodomie tu dis que c'est comme
christophe colomb quand il a découvert
l'amérique ce qu'il a découvert par
hasard on va être un jour tu aller
tromper quoi j'ai glissé je tue c'est
vrai ça ah oui absolument veut
d'ailleurs ma partenaire sur
l'interphone parfois à plus tard elle a
rien dit oh non non pas du tout à la
fois du temps de ce que tu dis ça tu dis
qu'au début les femmes sont réticentes
fin dans tes expériences puis que
finalement elles sont toutes d'accord
bout d'un moment
oui à condition qu'on le considère pas
la sodomie comme une façon de châtier ou
des death a dit qu'il faudrait c'est un
acte d'amour c'est pas le pouvoir dans
ton niveau qu'un liberté à la sodomie
c'est une façon de finir une femme était
alors évidemment ça peut être mal est
une punition
enfin moi j'ai jamais forcer personne
n'a pas peut-être pas et la sodomie
c'est un plaisir partagé
j'aime bien ça toi oui j'aime beaucoup
pourquoi parce que le rectum à une forme
pas comme le vagin il ya des choses plus
en âge l'expliquent par exemple moi j'en
ai lu mais je recule explique aux gens
qui bravant la vie mécaniquement c'est
parce que la friction sur l'un verger
par exemple il ya juste la rampe au sol
à amp il ya juste dix ans le l'entré
deux
de l'anus quand ils vous feront le reste
après on est dans un grand vide donc
comme ça frotte pas beaucoup de temps a
fait dix ans que ces salhi castan
on est là mais le groupe est à facebook
1 pour apprendre gens pour faire
partager aux gens tombent si tant côté
pédagogue comme quand tu vas donner des
cours dans les écoles où c'est pour
faire du plein de folie maintenant pas
du tout j'ai vécu ce livre par plaisir
personnel pour un petit peu faire le
point sur mes quatre ans de faire
l'amour et non pas seulement ceux mes
sentiments quelques jours je me suis dit
dans le fond et les sentiments c'est
beau mais ya pas de ça et le reste on
n'en parle jamais le nom que j'ai essayé
de faire un petit point
habile de rang quelques fortes le fonds
réunit 34 ans n'avait pas été démontrée
de presse mais justement tu l'a écrit
par petit pas petit paragraphe a écrit
quand il ya le soir en rentrant chez toi
le message était un petit chapiteau
mais quand il y avait un truc qui me
venait à l'esprit qu'à pris du plaisir à
l'écrire car beaucoup de plaisir oui ça
t'a fait bander l'écrire ce lille là oui
certaines craintes parce qu'il ya des
souvenirs s'est arrêté pour s'être
masturbé oui oui parfois oui